he caught a touchdown in the first Super
Bowl NFL Network ever covered and now he
will be part of the seven and a half
hour pregame show on NFL Network on NFL
gameday morning prior to Super Bowl 54
here in Miami he is none other than 16
year veteran of the game five-time Pro
Bowler and I shall say it future
hall-of-famer Steve Smith good to see
you sir hey rich much indeed all right
what do you think of this uh this game
that's coming up I know you and Deion
we're chit-chatting a little bit about
this could be the most evenly matched
Super Bowl that we have seen would you
agree with that Steve number one defense
number one offense you got two teams
that really know exactly who they are
they have a true identity a lot of times
you get teams that get it to the Super
get into the playoffs trying to make it
to the Super Bowl and what do they do
they lose their identity they try to
trick you try to do some things
uncharacteristic and I really look at it
I'm a food guy I work out to eat mm-hmm
and I look at the Super Bowl is you know
when you go to you talk about a food
week in a city mm-hm and you go to a
restaurant and they have all the preset
menus you know the regular seasons like
the appetizer yes right and the playoffs
really are the main dish is the domain
appetizer but the Super Bowl is really
to submit the whole meal
it's the dessert and we all know
especially if you're on a date which is
significant other your wife no matter
how many years yeah man if the appetizer
is fantastic and the main courses soup
indus finger-licking good and you get
that little dessert wine and if the
dessert sucks you could pretty much put
a fork in B drive home I do
trying to sit here and figure out a
follow up with a question off of that
Steve but that is an understandable
yes it's relatable I totally understand
so then I guess who's got the best
dessert chef pastry chef yeah who's got
the best pastry chef in Super Bowl 54
I did not think I'd be setting up a
question that way but you have led me to
it what I love Andy Reed understands
exactly what he wants
I think eat do yeah he coaches to you
yes Bryce is know you know you're all
right you know be confident your own
skin mm-hmm and I love what Andy Reid
does he understands exactly what his
identity of his team as he understands
his his quarterback had he traded for
Alex Smith as well so he knows exactly
what he wants how to does it the thing I
love by any read and there'd be enemy
and that staff offensively is they
understand how to set up they put guys
in position and Andy Reid is a great
play designer however he's an excellent
play caller mm-hmm right and some of
these teams that have these use a guy
like Matt naggy excellent play designer
but I believe because of his his in his
lack of experience of his quarterback
that was thrusting on to him prior to
his employment of being a Chicago Bear
head coach an offense coordinator at
times because of that quarterback he
lacks the ability sometimes to the
execution of that play design and
sometimes it limits what kind of play
that coach can call based on what his
offense can and cannot do what their
weaknesses and strengths are so that's
what I love about Andy Reid but I also
love Kyle Sienna and he understands
exactly what he wants to do he is going
to run the ball and if you don't know he
will run the ball and if the pass isn't
going well
he's gonna run the ball and what I
really love about that is he's not shy
about it
mmm-hmm and so you know Kansas City
Chiefs are gonna run I'm he gonna pass
the ball they run it here and there and
you know
that census go 49 is it gonna run a ball
and pass it here and there now it's just
the work of the defense to figure it out
I think it's in just a another way of
saying it's an evenly matched Super Bowl
but it is where we're however
experienced would be on Reed side and
obviously Kyle Shannon is not as
experienced but he was an OC in a Super
Bowl we all know and of course has been
around football for ever in a day
through his dad yeah so there's even
that sort of offset Steve Smith here on
the Rich Eisen show in terms of
experience playing in the Super Bowl
there's not a lot of guys obviously
Richard Sherman and is an OG and T
sizzle for Kansas City you were in year
three when he played in your Super Bowl
and you strolled him what was that
experience like that a lot of these guys
will experience on Sunday when they
stroll out into Hard Rock I think
ignorance is is bliss in this situation
because you don't over think when I was
in Baltimore on the things I realized
when I when I woke up a few few mornings
and I realized you know I just don't
have the speed at 37 that I had at 27 so
there were times where my coach Bobby
Engram who's the tight ends coach which
is why the tight ends for the Baltimore
Ravens are really really good yeah is he
said quit overthinking I would catch a
pass because I don't have the speed that
I used to I would try to try to mind
manipulate well if I catch this I turn
here and Juke this he said just catch
the ball and go forward because there
are a few games where I tried to trick
everybody and all I was doing was
tricking myself
it sounds like catch the ball and going
once I got out of that habit sometimes
knowledge you know it's paralysis by
analysis sometimes you can overthink so
some of the young guys I really love
their naiveness because they're coming
out they're saying man we in the
Superbowl but it's just another game but
we know us know next week so let's go
ahead and risk it all so did you think
it was really just another game when you
were heading to NRG Stadium or whatever
the heck it was called back in the day
and he
and you're taking on Tom Brady would
just won it two years before the
beginning no in the middle of the game
it was like it's still a football game
if we want a host of Lombardi Trophy we
got to just go out here and play this
guy's gonna press me what are you gonna
do this get a guy pressing you in the
Super Bowl is no different than a guy
press you in a regular season because if
you don't win and it's third in fiber
you you're running that slant he knows
you're on the slant he's pressed inside
you got a win you know the balls coming
if you don't catch that ball they're
punny whether it's in a Super Bowl
regular season the defense is still
gonna look at you on the way Ian they're
gonna go can you guys move the ball it's
still a football game the goalpost is
still in the same place it sounds just
like the Hoosiers you ever see the movie
Hoosiers where coach Dale measured the
rim to the floor and the free throw line
to the end line it's just because it's
at Butler Fieldhouse it doesn't matter
it doesn't you have to you it's hard to
do but at some point during the game
you'll realize maybe it's going across
the middle somebody hit you I was still
still a football game they hit in the
Super Bowl just like you don't hit in a
regular season Steve Smith here on the
Rich Eisen show and in that Super Bowl
I've never asked anybody who's playing
the Super Bowl this question did you
know what happened at halftime and what
at what happened at halftime with the
wardrobe malfunction did you know during
the game no you had no idea no when did
you learn about that when you just got
home or something like that or when the
rest of the guys that's full that's
literally all the country was talking on
Twitter and everything else we lost that
game yeah so I was so done with whatever
news information I mean so you know some
of the some of the guys do it now they
look at them for you know Twitter and
all that stuff but you know during a
game and a half time but when you lose a
game like that in a way we lost how
close you don't go back and see what
they're saying mm-hmm about the game you
experienced that you know the fourth
quarter of that game was insane I mean
there was about 40 points almost scoring
that quarter alone like it just seemed
like everybody was the defense's were
gassed and the offenses that were were
hitting the gas it was amazing one of
the things that nobody really gives this
guy enough credit for was there's a guy
I think he's vice president on Buffalo
Dan Morgan he had like twenty two
tackles in that day nobody really knew
he was a tackling machine Dan was all
over them like that right now it's
interesting you you were you were
I guess just in Carolina right I mean
where there was an announcement that was
going on there you were telling the
story about how how you hear sometimes
where players will look around the
locker room and say we may not see each
other again quite some time would you
tell that story you were telling that
story off set you know it was it was
amazing yeah this is Dan hinting we're
sitting in the locker room and we're
sitting in our office of media and Dan
he looks around and he says men look
around remember everybody's face when
was this like early on in your career
know this was in the Super Bowl okay
this is in the Super Bowl in Houston he
said look around remember this remember
these guys because you will never have
these bunch of men out seeking one
common goal in one place at the exact
same time in the same exact jersey and
he just laid out everything about it
what we were wearing what were you
eating just he just summarized it up and
he said so remember no matter what the
outcome is you none of the you will ever
be in this room ever again doing this
you may do it with another team you may
do it for another group of individuals
we may be back here next year but five
of you guys I guarantee you will not be
back here because that's just way life
work he says this before the Super Bowl
he says was four Super Bowl so he says
until unless you want to change it you
can't but so you might as well go out
there it just bust your tail put it all
out there and know at some point where
you guys come back you guys will talk
about it because you'll never ever do
this again
so fast forward I'm in Carolina and Matt
rules press conference one of the guys
that was in that room named Brad Hoover
Brad Hoover was our fullback what the
Coastal Carolina he's a legend in
Carolina they love him
I hadn't seen Brad Hoover in ten years
prior to that day when I see him at rule
at his press conference and it hit me
when we did our when we did our thing I
was like wow
Matt rule brought us together however
this Sun gun there's three miles from me
he lives three miles from my house his I
was in my own
he said you still I said I'm still over
here you stole he's like yeah and it was
crazy because when we did our show we
did a production meaning and because of
that it reminded me of that story I have
I went I'm played a football game with
one of my closest friends at that time
and yet we stayed out of touch for 10
years and it just is summarized really
you know fancy this has you know a lot
of fancy this on the couch and I go I
could do this oh I could be here I could
do that
but a lot of these men and women now
that put so much time and effort into
this game and I've learned it as an
analyst we show up so many hours before
but there are so many men and women who
laid a carpet you're the lighting yeah
why the football players are sleep while
we're eating pregame meal they're doing
all those things so as analyst I won
things as I really feel ashamed of and I
said now is I didn't appreciate I
believe
the engine the wheels and the tires that
helped all this go on see we're just the
cute cars the luxury vehicles but
without the tires without the spark
plugs being changed without - all
without the radiator without the
windshield wiper fluid being refilled
none of this exists and I didn't know
that as a player so now is the analyst
when I go on set a lot of times or if I
don't sit down interview I shake the
hand of every camera man or woman
because if they don't do their job I
look stupid or some people that's
watching this stupid er depends on nice
right so that that's one of the things
that as a football player
I feel ashame I didn't respect but now
as an analyst I respect the men and
women that allow us to get our game
started that we the game is gonna be at
what eight o'clock however there are
people up 3 4 or 5 a.m. in the morning
getting things prepared oh don't no
doubt amen to that
I'm into that and everybody that's
obviously here right now on the set - we
make this you know I mean we're in this
beautiful spot that once it's all over
we'll go back to being a parking
structure and it looks beautiful right
here because of all the hard work that
everybody's been putting into it and
again in the same way I think this week
more than ever has crystallised love
what you do when you do it and live in
the moment as best you can because you
never know how things will change and in
the same way that we're all here at this
show at the Super Bowl who knows when
we'll all be together again and that
what a message that Dan Henning
delivered to you I think we'll be
together on Sunday well that is for
seven and a half hours that is that's a
fact that is and that is absolutely fact
in its game prediction time presented by
DIRECTV 4k a quick reminder that the big
game on Sunday is brought to you by 4k
HDR by DIRECTV
all right Steve Kansas City or San
Francisco what do you have in this one
being a 49ers fan I would love to see
them win as I am a 49ers fan grew up my
grandpa was an Oakland Oakland Raider
fan but I got the Kansas City Chiefs
do I have a score I have no score well
you got a few days to figure that so I
don't I don't know school thanks for
coming on Steve Smith thanks Adam I will
see you at our meeting we were supposed
to be from six or seven everybody's
there not a chance not a chance that
meetings an hour yes it's a seven and a
half hour show yeah right I mean seven a
half-hour show so off air what will make
a will make a candy wager no a bag of
whatever manse or whatever yeah who will
be late and how late they shall be hmm
well it won't be me it won't be me I'll
be there right on time okay you know
that and that won't be you know
it'll be Michael everything all right
we'll be back good to see you man let's
see at Steve Smith right here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app